Now Peacock is launching its own elderly
dating show, The Solid Gold Bachelor.
I don't know, man.
The Golden Bachelor works because Gary is so
charming. Right now, this solid gold
bachelor, he better be a gentleman like
Gary.
Well, here's the crazy thing.
This guy is also named Gary.
So please welcome Gary.
Atricin.
Gary. Wow. Wow.
Thank you, young blood.
Ah! Hey what's up man?
Yeah, okay. Thank you.
Okay, now it's actually pronounced Geri,
Geri Atric.
Got it. Oh, wow.
Got it.
Well, Kenan, you didn't tell me that.
That's my bad.
Okay, Geri Atric, I apologize.
Yeah, well, answer this for me, Jerry.
Why do you think that they cast you to be
the solid gold bachelor?
Well, I'm
in my 70s. I got a lot to offer.
I'm a successful restaurateur, a deacon at
my church, and I'm in three pickleball
leagues. Oh. All right, and let me tell
y'all something. I got the utmost respect
for all the females.
Love the women. That's really good.
That's a good thing. Especially if they got
a nice ass.
Come on. And by nice, I mean athletic,
thick, juicy like an apple.
Yes. If apple was a pumpkin.
All right. And if a pumpkin could jiggle it
got to have that jiggle. Gotta have.
You know what I mean. You got to be careful.
A lot of fabulous fakes out there.
So you got to examine it.
All right? You know, make sure it's God
given. You know what I'm saying?
I like my booties. Organic?
Yeah, organic. Created by God.
Hallelujah.
All right. Do you have a type?
No, man.
Uh uh, she ain't got to know how to type.
No, you're making me a little uncomfortable,
you know? Just. Is this is this why your
first marriage didn't. Didn't last?
No, actually, my wife died.
Oh, shoot. Well, come on, Keenan, I'm sorry
to hear that.
Yeah. It's okay.
She died of natural causes.
Oh, I'm. I'm sorry for your loss.
Well, at least that's what the jury
believes. Come on, Jerry, come on, come on,
Jerry, don't laugh at that.
No, Jerry, you laugh at that because you got
to wait. I got to.
Come on now. Look, I think it's I think it's
very important thing to focus on is that
you're just never too old to find love.
Let's get back on track.
Love is a strong word.
They're young blood.
But the right woman was strong values, a
good soul.
And a checkbook as fat as that pumpkin ass.
All right. Who? Okay, now she might be able
to lift my spirits.
And by spirits, I mean.
Oh, hey, hey! Come on, stop that!
Hey, my big boy! Stop it, my Johnny!
Ronnie! Come on.
My stick.
Okay. My pipe.
My rod. You want to go?
My man thing, Mr.
Ooga booga. Boom, boom.
Yeah! Do it quick!
Don't touch me with your dick.
Definitely touched you with his dick.
Yeah, he was touching me with his dick.
With my dick arm. Come on, Jerry.
Hey, I'm old, but I'm not dead.
Okay. All right. I think it's pretty clear
that your show will be very, very different
from the Golden Bachelor.
I don't even know if I'm going to be around
for all ten episodes.
So that's why we're doing Fantasy Suite on
night one.
Panties dropping.
Okay. You know.
Hey, dolls, hit the floor.
All right, all right. I ain't getting any
younger, and neither is my.
Hey, come on.
That's the second stop doing the big dog.
Come on, my stick.
Stop my pipe! My ride.
My baby leg.
Ain't no pinky toes up in here.
Look out! It's coming!
Yeah, I got come on, man, stop poking me with
that. Jerry. Jerry guy.
Jerry!
Stop around.
Wow. You put me in the middle.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. The devil tap.
I guess we can just say good luck, Jerry.
And we we hope that you find your second
wife, man.
Oh, they ain't never gonna find my second
wife. All right, I cannot, and I will not
endorse your show.
No, no, listen, I'll do it, guys.
The solid gold Bachelor Geri Atric, Geri.
Geri Atric. That's it.
Where's he going? The exit is that way.
He don't.
That's my bad. That was a Craigslist gone
wrong.
Oh my God.